le changement d'heure et la hantise de
certains parents d'enfants en bas âge la
certitude pour eux de nuit perturbée et
de réveil compliqué ce serait certain
que d'adapter la routine de sieste ça ça
peut être un défi ensuite il y a les
endormissements qui peuvent devenir un
petit peu plus difficile les
conséquences sur les tout-petits ne se
limitent pas au sommeil agité perte
d'appétit et troubles de l'humeur
peuvent survenir et puis ça peut même
venir jouer sur le système immunitaire
un enfant fatigué peut être plus enclin
attrapé différents virus pour faire un
passage en douceur il n'existe pas de
recette miracle c'est vraiment d'y aller
au niveau graduel à coup de 10 15
minutes aux deux trois jours puis encore
là de voir comment l'enfant réagit
chaque fois qu'on doit avancer ou
reculer nous montre le débat ressurgit
faut-il maintenir cette pratique ou bien
la volière j'aimerais mieux rester
comme ça là au moins on sait où on va là
après on avance on recule ras-le-bol un
peu aucun problème
je trouve ça sympathique aussi ça rythme
l'année je suis plutôt contre je dirais
je pense que c'est beaucoup de
changements pour le corps pour pas grand
chose la Société Canadienne du sommeil à
elle aussi un avis sur la question la
conclusion pour nous c'est
500 changer là gardons leur normal comme
l'humanité a évolué et on devrait
s'emporter beaucoup mieux il y a moins
de problèmes de santé qui vont en
découler l'été dernier elle a adressé
ses recommandations à Ottawa au Canada
le temps légal et du ressort des
provinces et des territoires ainsi la
Saskatchewan et le Yukon sont les seuls
à ne plus changer d'heure pour sa part
le Québec se dit ouvert à la discussion
mais ne bougera pas si ses voisins ne
font rien de leur côté et à ce moment-ci
ce n'est plus une question
d'effets sur les gens ou communication
scientifique s'est rendu une question
politique en mars dernier les sénateurs
américains ont voté à l'unanimité
l'abandon définitive du changement
d'heure mais pour devenir effectif ce
projet de loi doit être adopté par la
Chambre des Représentants et promulgué
par le président Joe Biden le Mexique
lui a décidé fin octobre de ne plus
passer à l'heure d'été dès l'année
prochaine ici Vincent Pichard
Radio-Canada Québec